President Trump may strike back and
former high-ranking national security
officials who have repeatedly criticized
him the White House says the president
is thinking of taking away their
security clearances lawmakers say that
would be an unprecedented move making
the clearance process political major
Garrett is at the White House major good
morning good morning the White House
made this announcement after Kentucky
Republican Senator Rand Paul met with
President Trump and suggested it now
contrary to what the White House alleges
former top officials we have spoken to
in the intelligence community say that
they retain their security clearance to
assist the government after their
service by providing informal advice or
serving on boards and commissions in
essence helping the government and not
themselves the president is exploring
the mechanisms to remove security
clearance because they've politicized
and in some cases monetize their public
service and security clearances White
House press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders said those officials include six
former national security professionals
who condemned president Trump's signals
to Vladimir Putin on Russian
interference in the 2016 campaign of the
six former FBI director James Comey and
former FBI deputy director Andrew McCabe
no longer have security clearances on
Twitter former National Security Agency
and CIA director Michael Hayden said
revocation of his clearance won't have
any effect on what I say or write former
Director of National Intelligence James
clapper called it an abuse of the system
this is nothing short of treasonous
former CIA director John Brennan had
harsh criticism for mr. Trump's remarks
after he sided with the Russian
president over u.s. intelligence in
Helsinki last week I think anyone who's
calling basically the president
treasonous which would require the death
penalty is someone that is over-the-top
on Monday Kentucky Senator Rand Paul met
with the president calling for Brennan's
clearance to be revoked I have no
confidence in a guy like Brennan I think
he's a total lowlife but some Republican
lawmakers criticized the president for
even considering the action it's
somebody
breach protocol in terms of classified
material or break a law then they would
certainly be appropriate if it's not it
certainly would look to be just kind of
political retribution Maryland's
Democratic congressman Elijah Cummings
sharply criticized the white house
reminding it the president Trump allowed
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn to keep his security clearance
even after the Justice Department warned
the White House that Flynn was under
investigation for his contacts during
the Trump transition with Russian
officials deal all right major thanks
thank you
you know you have the conservative Wall
Street Journal editorial calling this
the dumb idea of the week it says it
looks petty essentially yeah and use the
word dumb yeah in the headline